hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome our looks like why Russian
volunteer mm-hmm
anyway and everything is freshly
non-blown up so I need to get a move on
um unfortunately I don't know if I'm
going to find out what happened to her
father not sure if it'll all mean
something of a blow this place up but
the one thing that I got to do is I got
to go over to the knurl mod division so
that I can get this damn hot oh my god
am I even going the right way
oh my god that was so scary
why were he's just Gary right I need to
figure out if we will no no that's the
hardware labs good god you ma'am jammers
I need to go in the neuro Montilla
vision it's where I came from
oh uh yah yah yah yah yah I know you all
God little Wong from here but ok ok so
that's where I first woke up from the
neural not division right now we all
know where that came from so if we go in
here we should be able to get the
lockdown lifted on the DRM pattern for
the neuro Mont fabrication plan whatever
yada yada I'm using big words because
I'm trying to sound important either way
I need to go in here real quick and then
I get back to the Arboretum to be able
to what I'm gonna do exactly but I'm
gonna be able to talk with my brother
and I don't know that's gonna be a happy
family Roo you were there but Kamali are
you dr. Equis are you approaching the
crew facilities if so this is a
sentimental request well my collection
the gallery of photos the others used to
laugh at each picture is a decryption
key to a set of neural data connectors
but guess who came to the station among
them Lightner the pianist
is
he's dead hmm okay we can't let those
skills be lost so this left of it please
Morgan if you can I would be great
okay go no mama be able to do that open
the safe in my roof okay thank you late
with your transcribe okay maybe I'll do
that
oh okay thank you I get it
all right I get it I just need to know
where I'm supposed to go for this I need
to get my optional objective done
because I need to find where the heck is
it
I need to get the thing unlocked in here
what the [ __ ] is it there we go I need
this so I need to look for that all
right papi puto oh I need to go up there
good good
it's not gonna be too far ah all right
okay oh hey hey hey hi hi get shrekt bad
oh no you got slowed okay these guys are
jumping out of the wall that mean I'm
much appreciate it
whoa whoa I don't remember it being this
dark in here okay
oh boy oh boy oh boy
ah okay what happening here
oh my game here thanks so much food so
much incredible lovely food with which I
can stuff in my pants and then carry
with me and then break down too and
space materials because I'm a weirdo
like that I'm an alien I don't actually
need to eat the food I just need to
carry with me so I can feel good about
oh okay alright the thing I don't need
to aim with this shotgun just general
direction is good enough apparently
Lucca is no contraband astana why I had
good that he has I can show you where it
keeps him but fair is fair you want is
good look the other way with me okay ah
[ __ ] sock yeah I'm yak like fine you
want to be like dad Moo oh hi what are
you Oh
oh that's no good at all well that's no
good at all
okay so powers out here I wanna know
what that was sounded bad okay so
nothing here this doesn't look like the
place I'm supposed to go why am i why am
i wallowing in the bathroom when I don't
really don't need to [ __ ] die how I'm
aware of that thank you
[ __ ] is popping out of nowhere
playing lockers to swage my feelings
emotions were highly damaged in that
surprise attack okay anything else god
there's so many crews see it doesn't
seem go this seems like a lot of crew
quarters but it doesn't seem like
there's a lot of different places for
with which there to be people
considering there's like an endless
supply of people on this station you
know oh I'm up now I don't want to be up
where you at Oh
where you at Oh No Oh
he'll walk clamp
Oh give me a lift feel now that's pretty
good
BAM lamb-lamb be' it got you good you
stupid zack a few at sneaking around a
dark like that have a patient pods know
where i need to be restricted that's a
thing there's something in there that i
need though hmm
how would i get in there I never figured
out how to get past these stupid pieces
of [ __ ] so there's got to be like a side
entrance in there that I can sneak
around it it's got to be because oh no
it's not in there well what am i doing
that's dumb it's not in there it's over
here oh I'm dumb never mind me never
mind me everybody but there's got to be
a way to turn on the power there if I do
need to go there let's try to figure
something else I need to go over there I
don't exactly know where there is but
hey I can hack that now no I can't but I
think I can figure out too because
pretty sure I got enough neuro mods to
be able to do that I've got seven
I need eight eight eight
[ __ ] you eight oh god damn it is that
neural madhavan it's fabrication so
maybe that's not where I need to go okay
we're on the map is this damned thing
where is it on the map oh that's helpful
it's on level 4 how the hell do I get to
level 4 god I don't even know who that
looks promising no that's not promising
okay
well I'm in a new area so that's nice
hmmm I turned on the power to the place
over here please let there be one neural
mod here I just need wine now no I need
whoa where'd you come from
alright I'll be with you in a second
let's see miss Goodwin I'm going to need
more support volunteers are hatchet ated
more than usual this morning sixteen
threatened to bash my head and if I
didn't let him out it stretches lame
when you get up here to keycode you 7703
not the old number on file I'm pretty
sure they've been watching me punch that
in so it changed it John thanks for
reaching out after she fellas are to
send a team to do a quick once-over the
premise is to ensure that you are
absolutely safe during the next shift
obviously the safety of our volunteers
and their security staff is our
number-one priority we unfortunately
can't post any more security personnel
to this location at the time but we're
looking to expand our security staff and
may be able to revisit this issue in the
future let me know if you have any
questions beyond good good ok what good
did that do
ah I unlocked the volunteer quarter
access I don't know where that is or why
that is or what even is in here why is
this here why was this open ooh can I go
up oh I can I don't know if I can but
I'll try Oh your your pity okay hello
where am i Oh way [ __ ] Wow
how about you don't but whoo hi there
you waved up but standing up like a
woman
ya ain't gonna work on me where am I now
i servitor I lie on the fourth wall way
and this oh hi
okay there's a lot of things out there
let me just pop over up recycler charge
over the little gap here
oh so alive dewpoint key here they're
going crazy but that's okay the process
doesn't hurt not at all be brandy grace
speaks happily enthusiastically there's
no henna pair plexus eating at her nerve
endings the Olympic medals lie in their
glass cases facing her like an audience
yet I still had my love of skating but
the skill felt trapped inside my head
the mods neuro mods allowed that skill
to be shared with others as a gift okay
nice
I got a hallway
well lump or major wampa John whoa hey
hey hey what the [ __ ] was that
oh I see you now all that is beautiful
is you ready for bubble in did that not
get you
[ __ ] move out out out
got so much food right that not hit it
too far too far as global wow wow wow
good thing I got food the only thing I
can say oh boy
okay oh [ __ ] it's gonna wait til my
cooldowns come up and I'm just gonna
black magic oh you're a corpse now baby
take it down to fall down to stay down
sack of [ __ ] alright moving on with my
life
imagine keyguard oh so that's how Dan
Greaves office that's the thing that I
need to unlock so the key to getting in
there was undoing the power disruption
so whoa so odds but no power alrighty
then hello ah that looks interesting I
don't have leverage 3 well door
actuators are wonky come see me if you
need in graves well huh
graves I do need to come see you for a
lot of things here gravy boy who oh no
it's where I was ok nevermind [ __ ] this
yet not bad don't need that any of this
[Music]
no easy enough your Frederick steel whoa
you had his office key why did you have
his office key huh well let's go to his
room and see if he has a key code before
I go hacking into that thing the where
oh where oh fabricator not yet not yet
not yet up there that's right Hakeem up
there I'm gonna go back off because I
got nothing better to do you let me baby
grave is gonna have to wait get in there
without me getting leverage three Trudy
no no no no I went the long way around
to that nobody questioned why I just did
that it's not important no whoa hey down
boy or girl okay Alden grave can you
fricking unlock the thing well where do
you think you think it comes from you're
sitting on the station's largest store
of it you haven't wondered what it is
they have us injecting into her frontal
lobes you're brilliant graves but you
have the mind of an engineer good
answering questions but not asking them
hi I could have been an engineer second
guessing the youth Oh the use never
struck you until you saw that report
from psychotronics didn't it I don't
know baby
I don't know we have four new robot ear
in the test labs we received four signs
before and therefore in secured storage
if you're saying you ship seven I advise
you to take it up with security in your
delivery personnel this isn't the first
time neural mod have gone missing
somewhere between fabrication and
testing people want them real bad
ah
okay all right sure neural mod licenses
boom finally Oh finally P good god about
damn time for that the fly uh I bet that
and horribly okay I think that's
everything I needed in there except the
nightmare hunting you that massive
typing appeared shortly after you
installed alien neuromas you mean oh I
don't like that oh oh I don't like that
why did you do that to be that scared
the bejesus out of me oh my god [ __ ] ID
chills running down my spine
it all comes from then get it out now oh
my god so what happens if I actually try
to kill it Hawk OH
let's listen to this and guess just got
a minute
it's my day off yeah but can you run me
through the container docume seeds or
again mystery man please if I ask Gus
again he loses are you at the crate
talking control-c and handling number on
the container you want a dog yeah where
you go what do I get the numbers are you
laughing born here Oh once you enter the
number you should do some pop-up select
doc that's it you can say to just knock
cells right yes bring in Da Nang they're
all yes piloting and I guess open opens
the container yes but both ends can
never be open at the same time that way
the interior don't even
I can get you I don't know that 100 I'm
out of ammo for that I didn't think that
would happen
oh sorry II know I know I [ __ ] that up
oh he [ __ ] that real good try this oh
wow oh my god whoa that's turning your
green I guess oh the thing that happened
wow I'm dead now apparently I almost had
him
I mean I can do that better if I'm just
not stupid about it I don't know where
he went
oh hey all we should have done a better
time not today look like you're about
Oliver and ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha that's a lot of Gulu iPhone
cortex you see I don't know how useful
that is but I'm a scarf down some food
hopefully that's gonna clear up some
name group
oh boy well I did pretty good there and
I also unlock the fabrication plans
which is pretty good for me because now
I can make all the neuro mods I want
whoo whoo and I don't need to get
hacking anymore because I just came out
the door that I just went in so that's
good for me and I can get a whole mess
of exotic material out of that bad boy
right there ok so all I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna head back I'm gonna probably
stop by my office before I go up to
Alex's office but then I am going to
Alex's office I'm clearing out all this
garbo oh my god I'm in the fire boy hey
good boy co-op is it a good oh yeah
goodness gracious goodness gravy man you
know to think that van Halen would not
be hunting me if I'd never injected any
of the alien neural not doing one
haven't had much success in calling up
more fabrication blends but I did have a
design for a psycho scope chips cos I've
been tinkering aha the honor distant
found some useful okay maybe if it's
gonna be actually useful to me
mmm-hmm we make another Moreau Mon yeah
we do then I am all about making as many
neurons possible at this point but
people can make more - excuse you excuse
you
now is not the time for that
the blue scheme you got bad and whatever
we got we can't make anything oh we can
make all the super pair kids we warrant
I'm not a satellite project dealing with
remote psychotronic signalling our PSS -
x5 I think you could smooth venerable
Zakir that matches yours plain English
look you could use it to get that new
Newington off your back well I was
damaged though you didn't define a
replacement part
they both okay well I mean I guess
that's okay they didn't agree for the
cue believe all new fusion we all do
excuse their comments they're cheap boy
it's off now they can do so much more
oh you have an in conversation right
next to me alone is reassuring me to the
Cuba yeah feel good okay groovey nobody
got children I wish I wasn't part of
this conversation
what do you know mommy's make it over to
you my power cricket what you owed me
one my governing to react on wushu okay
alright friends here we're all friends
we're all friends being friends friendly
friends thank you Mike move of Google
Dom oh who are you talking to you're
talking about my not shooting my friends
gun oh yeah then I love that all right
now I got that where's this chip chat
set set sets you were talking about yeah
chip set
chip set i don'ts give me chips out here
I'm gonna pretend like you don't know
what you're talking about
I'm gonna open this and then I think no
those only salvage it why did I make
those Ben I thought those salvage didn't
do a mineral material but apparently I
was wrong let's go away from that
awkward situation and hopefully
skedaddle on away which way do we need
to go we need to be elevator go right to
the Arboretum there
oh they don't know one more thing
[Applause]
got a power but okay I guess whatever
whatevs brother Grantham grin cool okay
[Applause]
okay okay whoa hey that was fun
why that happens really glad that
happened yeah
oh good I'm here so happy about that
can you click gun again hopefully love
that love that a lot that's great okay
so once we get in here we go straight up
to Alex's office and we have a
confrontation with him to understand
what is going on in this world what in
the hell were you thinking Alex putting
aliens in people's brains I've had it up
to here with you oh you piece of [ __ ]
all right where we are oh that's new
tactically speaking that's good Rick
okay I'm gonna shoot you now video oh
wow
ow ow ow ow ow ow can you one of those
please oh hey hey hello Danny how you
doing 9:08 plus operator direction line
okay please can you just kill me and not
push me into the open don't forget to
complete a patient questionnaire yeah
that's still oh I missed it that's why
okay oh poor medical operator oh poor
guy okay but that doesn't matter because
there's a Weaver right out there and I'm
just gonna you know I'm just gonna walk
[ __ ] walk oh boy
alright we're fine fine fine
hey whoo hi what's the hole why okay all
right you know I'm just gonna oh we're
just gonna casually oh that's the wrong
number three seven two six and there we
go and there we go whoa all right we
made it
nailed it real good real good okay what
else is here on the outskirts of this
sumbitch here we got oh an apple I took
Alex's favorite Apple people be so
pissed I don't see anything else here oh
there's an upstairs
hello
ilex I won't be joining you don't worry
there's no trick just a gift from your
big brother it's the truth like I
promised me a while to dig it up some I
wanted to hide it from you my computer
another video give it a look and we'll
talk I'm sending you the password
assuming you haven't hacked your way in
yet okay this is uncomfortable is he
okay I didn't throw very far but
whatever I asked Brandi if she felt
betrayed by her pair of legs she nodded
not an agreement but understanding my
point because they discovered they could
map my brain but I can't accept a neural
mod myself her smile became firmer I
think that makes her gift more
meaningful it would be a year before it
was quietly decided by transpire to
receive no further neural maps connect
tones from para plexus patients citing
unspecified risks
okay kang seongjin okay oh that's nice
all these are nice here I'll take those
oh oh another thing oh good yes a weapon
upgrade kids the first thing that I
would want to lounge with clue skiddo
ski emails results of Morgan eval your
sibling is indeed different I've sent
the comparisons to you and Bellamy for
evaluation as you'll see there's
noticeably per there's noticeable
personality drift more than I'd expect
from heavy neural mod cycling it's even
more prominent because of the duration
in which these behavior shifts have
developed as requested I did not discuss
this with Morgan interestingly Morgan
seems unaware of these shifts as an
aside I believe this poses an
interesting question for other
applications in Ihram odd not solely
therapy but reconditioning see Alex you
made it my duty to keep everybody on the
station in good physical condition the
last time I checked sir you are part of
everyone on the station by my count
you've missed the past five scheduled
fitness tests if you're uncomfortable
with some of the exercises and
performing them in front of the crew I
can schedule you time in the fitness
center where it's just the two of us
remember you wouldn't just be doing this
to help yourself but to set an example
for the whole staff oh it's this okay
spoke to Lorenzo got no response so
bringing the matter you this oh I've
read this one actually I actually
already have ah the missing key card
Sarah I need your help tracking down a
missing key card this one should be of
your highest priority that's labeled EP
101 let me know when you find it found
it in a remote division on top of a
computer cabinet I'd say someone who's
trying to hide it along with what looks
like a bug-out bag should I be concerned
about anything it's still there by the
way
oh you didn't grab it
files oh I already had that why wouldn't
I have had that all right fine then
whatever movie we extend bridge yes
please unless that connects me to demon
then no thank you
I'm a lots of it oh my god if I don't
know this bridge would have taken so
long I would have just watched the video
anybody know it okay
main screen Oh rather of mine no it's
not accidentally blow this [ __ ] up
because I've done that before all right
what do we get my name is Morgan you
here is 2035 I'm aboard the talus one
research facility what else why are we
making this video right because my Big
Brother's paranoid psychometric data is
showing statistically significant
variance and personality patterns
between trial runs or the new neural
mods whatever I feel more like myself
than ever I mean look at this we did it
Alex it's real enjoy while you can
because in a few minutes it will all be
gone and we strip out the neural mods
and we said I know including my memory
of it no way around it let's talk about
the backup so the type and organisms
have been producing an elaborate
structure material is unknown purpose
unknown and my gut tells me it's a kind
of neural framework but externalized
still waiting on analysis to confirm in
the meantime I've given Alex the design
for a device I think could shut it down
if it ever broke containment Alex just
have to grow up here and commit you know
that to take all credit but if it
doesn't work it'll work trust me what
else we going to do blow everything up
that won't save us and if it does work
is it worth it the people that come
after us will be smarter stronger
immortal they can judge us if they want
but don't know they exist because of the
things we did
I'm ready do it
oh that's so weird
okay Wow
oh you haven't everything I've done
that's what you've asked me to do I
didn't think you'd believe me unless you
heard it from your mouth the tests they
changed you not a lot of first but
eventually the constant stripping of
your memory I didn't know who you were
anymore
all I want is it have my brother back so
we can finish what we started the device
you mentioned there's an advanced
version of the null wave it's the only
way to stop the typhoon without
destroying everything we've been working
toward we're just missing some scanned
data from the Carl to complete the
design help you finish this Morgan and
then you can have my arming key I don't
believe if you want to use it anymore
but you can have it
I love the chipset for you on my desk
you'll need to upgrade your psyche a
scope to scan the Carl I'll send you the
Scan locations oh that's so weird
that's so weird so there's like a choice
here this is the choice clam what do we
got hello I'm here now
ooh Alex's see oh there was a
maintenance bandar-log done that oops
okay so I think that Jarman key is in
here anyway
yeah might as well grab it again
a lot fellas safety avoid follows one is
persons responsible get as bad as they
probably are your only option is to
escape get the word out about what's
happening don't tell us one alex has a
private escape pod it's locked up I made
a copy of the key and hid it on top of
the data tower near the chair you know
the one I'm talking about
listen there's more at stake this time
than just us or this station if just one
of those creatures made it back home
then we're lost I keep having this dream
I'm just staring into the black between
the stars there's something there whoo
Morgan
that video was I'm still checking it
against my directives but as scanning
the coral will grant you access to
Alex's arming key then perhaps it's the
best course perhaps knowing the corals
purpose will reinforce your decision to
destroy Talos one just be careful
we're running out of time this is so
weird because I'm one thanks kid as bad
as they probably are your only option is
to escape well I don't
yeah what's happening maybe listen to
this
oh boy alex has a private escape pod
does doesn't mean locked up yeah I made
a copy of the key and hid it on top of
the data tower come here the janitor
maybe come in here you know the one I'm
talking about yeah I know the one you're
talking about there's more to take this
time than just us or this station it's
just one of those creatures made it back
home then we're lost
whoa I keep having this dream I'm just
staring into the black between the stars
there's something there I know there is
I just can't see it but it sees me hmm I
can feel it hate us mm-hmm
I know you know what I'm talking about
or you will so oh I don't know anything
me from the past I don't know anything
about nothing all I know is that I've
got a chip set now I do anyway
whoo hi you have enough Typhon material
in your system the turrets will consider
you a threat gray where is my gosh there
it is scope chipsets I need crystal
critical
I need where is it is it in the suit
ship since last chance
ah but these are what I need but I can
at least add these in on laughs and then
glass okay and then scope chipsets how
do you upgrade your scope to have more
Oh psychotronic skills will unlock more
okay but I need the shielding what the
[ __ ] is it wait where is it I thought it
was here did I get a fabricator plan for
it or did I actually get it what oh oh
hang on a second there's got to be like
I had to have got it
notice I thought I did didn't I I
thought I did I could've sworn I did I
thought I did I did
oh hi what the [ __ ] where did you come
from oh okay there it is then I think
okay let's replace ah replace this okay
actually I don't think it matters how
much that I have I think the dam is
excellent for me okay so how do I do
that so there's coral outside do I scan
the hats yeah right I'll try try buddy
boo hello-o
Coralie I would have unknown can I get
back no please can I have that this one
no right fine then
Oh Oh coral node I saw that well I saw
them oh I'm gonna get such a sneak
attack on you
Oh buddy boo you're not going to know it
hit you oh [ __ ] shields it down
get them down hang on I gotta get this
oh there you go where'd you go whoa I'm
screaming in terror with the yellow wool
confusion pretty go oh wow oh he ran
away
where's this coral node I saw it here
unless it was actually on the Weaver
might have been hang on let me see if I
can hunt this thing down eat some food
first
okay whoa whoa where'd you go
damn it keeps flipping me around dad but
I get it we bring here are you
where are you damn it where are you in
the band what happened [ __ ] is it I'm
gonna keep getting away from me like
that
what the [ __ ] this is hiding in the
brush we go you son of a [ __ ] oh you
sack of [ __ ] Oh
[Music]
final screw that hurt a lot you go I
can't even find your corpses to be able
to salvage man about the waste of time
oh [ __ ] dude can wear the goddamn are
the goddamn coral nodes you know what
I'm just gonna communication device what
the [ __ ] is that
I said goddamn there oh where am I
I know where I was okay whatever I'm
going to look up the objectives and I'm
only going to get the objectives that I
want not that one not not not not not
where is ah no that's part of the main
saw in the exterior okay so I gotta go
outside which means that I gotta go down
where it's telling me to go all right
now I'll listen to you you second
all right so let's get doodle outside he
did hopefully find ourselves a coral
node and get more to the bottom of this
mystery
cuz I am interested in discovering the
truth and the truth shall set me free or
else the truth will kill me I'm not sure
which one's which at this point the
truthful even tell me or it'll set me
free
come on work with microgravity
thank you that sounds men
I'm thinking about the video Alex showed
you your brother believes that version
of you is the true Morgan but why just
because it came first if someone had
made you and I suppose your truest self
would be the one that fulfills whatever
purpose your maker intended I know
mn why it's someone that you will get
home
I hate for something if not you'll have
to invent your own purpose or have none
at all
whole family of all the things I know
about you I don't know what you believe
you have to decide Morgan who are you
okay well that's ominous and rather
serious okay all right I'm gonna scan
the coral do you know just because I'm
gonna scan it you know cuz maybe it's
good I don't know I don't know what to
think it seems like I don't know I'm not
sure what it is
like why would Morgan that's the
question why would Morgan change his
mind over time if it was what he thought
of you know what I mean it was his idea
then oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm never going to
be able to kill the thing in time am i
oh boy oh that's not good I have known
well I don't have I will sighs oh no I
don't okay at least I drove it away
that's fine
from this platform Board of Directors
discord when of the situation here is
suppose it was inevitable despite my
efforts that's why it's important we had
quickly decisively
oh you don't okay
I'm damn it just run it go oh my god I'm
gonna die oh my god [ __ ] hell I just
want to get to the node oh just let me
scan this node let me scan it no you
don't scan scan scan I'm out of bullets
aw [ __ ] me dog [ __ ] you [ __ ] you that's
what I say to that that's [ __ ] one
side last seems to be enough to be able
to like this sways them from being
hassled about in their existence oh boy
that's too bad the club oh there were
not caught the black
oh [ __ ] and come on where did he go he
ran away no he didn't he's right there
no he's gone okay one at least one put
it away okay
just go in here around that's an option
oh oh [ __ ] off aah
Jeff was right there
ah [ __ ] dude oh man that means I gotta
go get some goddamn health oh [ __ ] okay
so unfortunately I got to go back and oh
my god shut up you shut up shut up shut
up okay so anyway unfortunately that's
all the time that I've got here I
actually wasted quite a bit of time this
episode just looking for where to go in
the crooner amat area and I have to
leave it is dark there why I don't know
I'm going to live just try to live just
trying to live please oh boy okay so
what I'm I do is I'm gonna find myself
some production capabilities I'm going
to restock because I am way out of my
comfort zone in terms of supplies but in
the next episode I feel we might be
approaching the end of this game so I
feel like the next video that you see
out of prey will be the final one
we'll see that when we come to it so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how i'm doing the comments
below and try not to spoil it for
everybody else you can't and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
[Music]